bonjour à tous la famille s'agrandit
cinq nouvelles communes rejoignent saint
quentin en yvelines
alors comment pourquoi et surtout qu'est
ce que ça change c'est ce que nous
allons voir ensemble dans ce nouveau
numéro de ski mag c'est parti
et
1er janvier 2016
un nouveau saint quentin en yvelines
voit le jour désormais l'agglomération
comporte douze communes elancourt
guyancourt la verrière magny les hameaux
montigny le bretonneux voisins le
bretonneux et rats auxquels s'ajoutent
les clayes-sous-bois coignières maurepas
plaisir et villepreux cette refonte
on la doit à la loi de modernisation de
l'action publique territoriale et
d'affirmation des métropoles promulguée
en janvier 2014
plus simplement on l'appelle la loi map
tam et pour comprendre exactement de
quoi il s'agit je vous propose d'aller
faire un petit tour sur les bancs de
l'université
vous ne certaine part de ce texte
concerne trait essentiellement le grand
paris la métropole du grand paris et
pour simplifier les choses
la philosophie du texte consiste à poser
que les collectivités qui côtoieront
ceux de rang paris donc qui seront à son
immédiate périphérie devront parvenir à
une dimension relativement importante
pour ne pas qu'existent des
déséquilibres trop fort entre ce futur
grand paris tout de même 7 millions
d'habitants et donc ses autres
collectivités ses autres jeux pc
établissements publics de coopération
intercommunale qui vont cendre entouré
cette très grosse collectivité
avec ces cinq nouvelles communes la
population de saint quentin en yvelines
atteint un peu plus de 230 mille
habitants on aboutit finalement à une
agglomération cohérente malgré un
calendrier serré et surtout bien loin de
la proposition initiale du préfet de
région
ce premier projet présenté en août 2014
prévoyait la création d'une
intercommunalité géante en fusionnant
saint quentin en yvelines versailles
grand parc le plateau de saclay
europ'essonne et la communauté de
communes de l'ouest parisien auquel ce
sera ajouté velizy verrières le buisson
vice ou de coignières et maurepas soit
près de huit cent mille habitants
impensable pour les élus saint
quentinois tout ça ce départ et c'est
démesuré d'ailleurs il ya eu aucune
aucune personne qui était favorable à ce
schéma là ce schéma vu sur 1000
donc le travail ensuite a été de pouvoir
obtenir une majorité qualifiée pour
proposer autre chose et dont ce qui
était proposé c'est finalement avoir une
intercommunalité à dimension humaine sur
un bassin de vie qui était compris par
tout le monde
si l'opération s'avère bénéfique pour
tous c'est avant tout parce que ces
nouveaux entrants apporte un vrai plus à
saint quentin en yvelines
alors qui sont ces nouvelles communes un
petit tour d'horizon s'impose villepreux
c'est un territoire d'environ 10
kilomètres carrés pour un peu moins de
10000 habitants fortement résidentiel la
commune est composé d'un centre
historique d'un coeur de ville plus
moderne et de vastes terres agricoles
l'atout majeur de villepreux
c'est son cadre de vie il ya à peu près
deux tiers des territoires qui est
vraiment concentré sur les espaces
naturels et agricoles
il ya différents centres commerciaux
niveau de la ville qui sont plus des
commerces de proximité
et puis ville est prête une ville
familiale avec une certaine forme de
mixité sociale
il ya un patrimoine qui est important
qui s'échelonne sur sur un certain
nombre d'années de période du plus
ancien au plus contemporain villepreux
partagent une gare transilien avec sa
voisine les clayes-sous-bois un peu plus
de 17000 habitants pour une superficie
d'environ six kilomètres carrés les
clayes-sous-bois compte plus de 400
entreprises installées dans cinq zones
commerciales et industrielles
nous avons la chance d'avoir une ville
qui est bien dotée en équipements
publics et qui a la particularité
d'avoir plus de la moitié de son
territoire en pleine forêt ou espaces
verts la commune est très dynamique sur
le plan économique puisque d'une dizaine
d'années la commune a créé un environ
que plus de 3000 emplois ce qui est
considérable pour une commune de notre
nombre d'habitats les clayes-sous-bois
ce sont aussi des centres commerciaux
régionaux ou année sean alpha parker 1
et alpha part que deux situées dans la
grande zone commerciale partager avec
plaisir plaisir et la plus peuplée des
cinq nouvelles villes qui rejoignent
saint quentin en yvelines près de 31
mille habitants pour une superficie
d'environ 18km au carré de gares
transilien de nombreuses terres
agricoles une vaste zone forestière mais
également plus de 900 entreprises
je pense également que le cadre de vie
qui est attendu par les personnes qui
travaillent dans ces entreprises et dans
ces commerces a fortement attiré les
entreprises on a quand même quand
entreprises comme le nôtre comme decaux
qui sont l'essence même de notre
collectivité on espère bien encore
développer puisque on a vraiment de la
matière et de l'espace et du foncier
pour pouvoir développer encore tout ce
centre économique et je me devrai
montrent au monde à venir non seulement
les entreprises mais aussi les habitants
et je peux vous dire que ça se sent jour
après jour que plaisir est vraiment une
attractivité départemental le dynamisme
économique
un point commun avec coignières moins de
5000 habitants environ 8 kilomètres
carrés et 800 entreprises et commerces
répartis sur 30 % de son territoire la
ville se revendique quatrième pôle
économique des yvelines la principale
zone commerciale est implanté le long de
la nationale et de la voie ferrée on y
retrouve par ailleurs une gare
transilien m
coignières c'est aussi un village c'est
aussi un village remarquable mais qui
n'est pas connu par nos amis qui
traverse le village par la nationale 10
mais c'est aussi un village ancien que
nous tenons à conserver
c'est un village qui depuis plusieurs
décennies a réalisé de nombreux
équipements
tout ceci a été réalisé grâce
effectivement à ce titre in commercial
voisine de coignières maurepas
revendique depuis toujours son statut de
ville à la campagne près du 19 mille
habitants pour un peu plus de 8
kilomètres carrés
nos repas est une ville boisé
résidentiel l'essentiel de ces
entreprises sont des commerces de
proximité et de grandes enseignes
implantées dans la zone paris ouest une
ville où il fait bon vivre dans laquelle
on se sent bien et je dire aussi c'est
une ville paisible maurepas est une
ville qui va se développer dans les
années à venir nous avons des projets en
commun avec la codi d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avec le
dédoublement du pont guy schuller pour
régler les problèmes de circulation mais
aussi pour créer une ligne de transport
en site propre c'est aussi le
réaménagement global du centre ville
pour trouver voilà une nouvelle ambition
pour nos commerces locaux pour favoriser
le stationnement pour favoriser
également l'accès piéton et vélo
vous l'avez compris cette
intercommunalité redessiné c'est aussi
l'occasion pour saint quentin en
yvelines de renforcer son développement
économique de la tpe à la multinationale
les milliers d'entreprises et de
commerces saint quentinois sont autant
de sources d'emplois et de revenus
permettant d'envisager un développement
du territoire
sur le long terme le modèle saint
quentinois est tellement sain qu'en juin
2014 l'agencé de notation standard and
poor's a confirmé les notes de ré
errances de la casse qui à long terme et
à court terme avec cet élargissement
saint-quentin-en-yvelines confirme sa
place de deuxième pôle économique de
l'ouest parisien et devient l'un des
plus importants pôles commercial
d'ile-de-france la surface totale va
être à peu près 300 mille mètres carrés
de surfaces de commerces de grande
distribution
jusqu'à maintenant c'est les différentes
communes avait d'elle-même créer des
zones commerciales de manière assez
indépendante
le fait qu'ils aient ces communautés
d'agglomération avec des missions de
développement économique qui soit vue
d'une manière commune et en concertation
pour le commerce ça peut être justement
quelque chose d'intéressant
le nouveau saint quentin c'est le
rassemblement de talents de très haute
valeur ajoutée de moyens
de deux logiques d'expérience avec une
seule obsession
comment on continue à servir au mieux
l'ensemble des habitants de cette
nouvelle intercommunalité avec ces
domaines économiques ces domaines
l'association les domaines culturel
sportif et c'est saint quentin en
yvelines c'est une une multipolarité et
7 multipolarité vraiment est essentielle
pour la vie des habitants avec les
services soient vraiment de proximité
donc utile à tout le monde c'est un
territoire où nous avons un bassin de
vie commun nous partageons les
transports les commerces les entreprises
la circulation donc je pense qu'on sera
beaucoup plus fort pour construire
justement l'avenir que cette
agglomération je crois que c'est un
territoire original qui doit garder
cette originalité pour être un
territoire complémentaires ce qui se
passe en première couronne ou à paris ce
qu'on peut souhaiter pour saint quentin
en yvelines pour ces communes pour le
territoire et pour ses habitants
c'est de continuer la dynamique la
dynamique de réussite celle qu'on a pu
développer ça ne s'est pas fait en un
jour
il faut le poursuivre c'est aussi le
sens de l'histoire
je vous rappelle que on revient aussi
sur le territoire initial de 50 euros de
mise lorsque la ville nouvelle a été
créée voilà ce qui m'agace c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très
vite pour un nouveau numéro
d'ici là portez vous bien ciao bye